i'm rachel franklin and i'm excited to
introduce you to the next generation of
the sims smart ursins sims with real
personalities and the stories you'll
tell about these sims will be
entertaining meaningful and sometimes a
little weird in previous games you
controlled the mind and body of your
sims in the sims 4 for the first time
you control their hearts here we are in
our creative sim where you decide what
your sims look like and brand new to the
sims 4 who they are you define your Sims
personality the traits and aspirations
that you choose influence their emotions
how they behave and how they respond to
other sims so you could make a
hot-headed athletes love literature or a
romantic nature lover with a touch of
insanity you have so many possibilities
at your fingertips so many sins to
create The Sims 4 features lively
vibrant neighborhoods rich communities
where anything can happen this is a deep
simulation where every sim has their own
story and they're all connecting
colliding and influencing each other's
emotions so the local gym is a great
place for me to show you how personality
and emotions influence your gameplay you
can tell how your Sims are feeling at a
glance happy depressed energized so
let's meet chucks
I've made him a hot head so he's already
prone to flying off the handle and I've
been pushing even further so today he's
really fired up and he's working out
those ABS well how did it get him into
this state it all kicked off last night
when I introduced Chuck to GLaDOS his
rather eccentric neighbor
I made Chuck recite some of his poetry
but I haven't leveled up his skills yet
and frankly his poems suck so this is
when the power of our simulation comes
into play
personality drives behavior creating
richer stories and in this case GLaDOS
hates Chuck's poem so much she decides
to get physical Oh Gladys losing really
ruined Chuck tonight and he's still mad
about it the next day no I feel bad
picture let's cheer him up and what
better way to do that than by throwing a
party so it looks like it's working
the neighborhood's shown up Chuck is now
feeling playful he's cracking jokes he's
becoming the life of the party
oh here's Gladys and she's still looking
for a fight her foul mood is affecting
everyone else I need to inject the dose
of funds in this party and I know just
how to do it
I will deep into the all-new gallery to
look for something special it's full of
wonderful homes and sims created by
other players and for the first time you
can share their sings
complete with their full personalities I
can bring another player's sim straight
into my game it's that simple so ladies
and gentlemen meet Princess now the
party is really booming
Oh check out those dance moves huh
Chuck's having so much fun II can't stop
laughing I'm pushing his emotions to the
extreme in fact he is laughing so hard
he dies of laughter so where else can
you find moments like this The Sims 4 is
unlike anything we've ever made
these new smarter Sims are full of
personality and humor and the
possibilities when you play with life
are simply endless we invite you to
create your own weird stories on
September 2nd when you'll get to play
with the next generation of the Sims
welcome to a world of exceptional Sims
where Sims with new emotions connect and
collide for the first time they're
smarter with big personality you create
them you control them their stories are
yours to tell their friends their family
they are neighbors
these are all new sins create their
stories and play with their lives like
never before
you